time now for the Ridiculist it's been a
while but it's back in tonight we're
traveling to a magical land far far away
a place so special it's almost like it
doesn't even exist allow me to explain
today the President of the United States
of America was at a meeting of African
leaders at the United Nations when he
straight-up made up a country I'm
greatly honored to host this lunch to be
joined by the leaders of Cote d'Ivoire
Ethiopia Ghana Guinea nambia yeah he
said nambia now I know what you're
thinking he obviously meant Namibia just
a slip of the tongue it can happen to
anyone right mmm
no listen in Guinea and Nigeria you
fought a horrifying Ebola outbreak
Gambia's Health System is increasingly
self-sufficient he thinks there's a
place called nambia maybe it's a
combination of Namibia which is a real
place I've actually it's lovely I went
when there for Christmas one year and
Narnia which is not though I wish it
were and I would love to go there if I
could only fit through that wardrobe
here's a map right there take a look you
see Namibia and right near it are Angola
Zimbabwe there's Botswana in there or I
guess if you're the president you can
just say them however you want nambia
and go go as in booby boots Walla Walla
for instance I just want to remind you
he was speaking to African leaders oh
and by the way the president might want
to consider taking a little break from
checking his favorite app tonight
because the Twitter people there on this
just a few of our favorites nambia the
world's top producer of Gogh FA but they
got a bumper crop of calf FA this year
by tomorrow Kellyanne Conway will insist
nambia is real by November it will be in
Texas who studies textbooks another one
why did Barack Obama never visit hashtag
nambia hashtag nambia is truly beautiful
this time of year everyone should visit
at least once in their lives just take
psilocybin to get there I'm told
psilocybin is the fancy way of saying
magic mushrooms and if I can learn to
pronounce psilocybin for a frigging
ridiculous I think the president United
States
take the time to learn how to pronounce
the names of other countries or at least
the ones that exist